Why AI is not writing all of the open
source in the universe?
>> Most people don't care. They just create
a PR and they put in code that they
think is good.
>> Open open source is a crypto project.
And that's a clip. We have a clip. Have
you ever open a pull request in a
massive open source project because
cloud code did it too and it's like more
than 40% of all of submission on GitHub
now. And Theo drop a video about open
source is dying. Is it true? Is it all
AI slope? That's what we're gonna talk
about in this video today.
>> Let's go.
>> Have you ever done any pull request to
go support on open source?
>> I have zero experience of open source
basically because I I had other stuff to
do.
>> First, we're going to start with the PR
spam problem. I've been pretty aware of
this for a while and I have a lot of
sympathy for people like TLR that put
out this change. So they are just
closing every external contribution
because it's getting out of hand to
basically manage all of the issues from
to perspective. That's basically killing
open source because then you don't have
contributors at all. So what's the
what's the point of open source, right?
>> Closing any external contributions
because they're just getting flooded
with them. And I knew how bad this was
and it helped other maintainers dealing
with it in the past. But this problem is
much closer to my heart now because
we're going through it ourselves. The T3
code codebase, which has been public for
about 5 days now, has 150 open PRs. Mind
you, we specified that we're not
accepting contributions and we still got
100 PRs a day for the first two days.
>> Remind me crypto projects.
>> Yeah. Yeah. People don't read, people
do.
>> People don't give a [__] And they will
do it because it will benefit from them.
And that's it. Open source is a crypto
project. And that's a clip. We have a
clip.
>> Yeah. I eventually added this because I
was tired of saying the same things over
and over again in all of the PRs and
literally all of my Sunday just sitting
going through PRs, testing things,
shipping new releases, just dealing with
that. Why?
>> He just said he wasn't going to do it
and now he still does it. So people are
now even going to put more PRs in.
>> Yeah, exactly. But like no, but what I'm
saying is like why is he doing it
manually?
>> I don't know.
>> Don't
>> maybe we should shoot in a PR telling
him, hey, autobated. I know he he he
explained that for a couple of site
projects he I know he covers all of
those processes with AI tooling already
right and he has a team so he has also
like two three dev I think to work on
those project too could be the scale
like I don't know the scale issue
>> yeah it probably is because otherwise it
doesn't make sense
>> we need to let go
>> oh yeah
>> we need to let go like the and trust
Trust AI.
>> But for him, for the pull request, he
was doing them all manually. I think
even if he just had an AI to take out
all the double ones, all the ones who
were obviously wrong,
>> that would [clears throat] have saved
him a lot of time.
>> For me, I basically couldn't do anything
Monday because I was so tired from the
whole weekend of triaging, managing PRs,
going through issues. I had to bring two
people on just to help keep track of the
PRs and issues.
>> And there's only 150 PR like right now.
>> And that's taking three people.
>> Mad. It's mad.
>> How many did Open Claw have? 5k.
>> Yeah. 5k. Yeah. Yeah. But the guy got
paid like 1 billion, so shut the [__]
up.
>> He doesn't care. He even pays a bill of
what AI kind of touches on this classic
post on Reddit.
>> I don't I don't give a [__] about the
[__] code. I just want to download
this stupid [__] application and use
it. Why is there code? Make a [__]
exit file and give me it to me. GitHub
is a tool for developers. If you're not
a developer, then GitHub is the wrong
place for you to looking for software.
And
>> and the worst thing is there are always
people replying. There is a high chance
that was a suggestion from Chad GP and
then it redirects
>> and someone filed a nonsense PR that
tried to fix all of those things and
ended up just breaking other things.
here is explaining like a big PR is hard
to it's basically garbage and it doesn't
follow the like the proper etiquette of
open source and even like software
engineering per se like on my local host
I will edit 1,00 file I don't do it on
an open source project after compare it
to another small pull request
>> you what Mitchell is creating you're not
familiar with him he's
>> the guy who made ghosty as well as
Terraform Mitchell knows his [__] he
built vouch because he was tired of the
nonsense PRs he was getting in things
like ghosty. So what is vouch? Community
trust management system. People must be
vouched for before interacting with
certain parts of a project. People can
explicitly be denounced to block them
from interacting with the project going
forward. Which crazy is that [__] is not
a [__] GitHub feature.
>> Yeah, you just allow some people and not
the whole world to just create pull
requests.
>> Still people can fork it and like star
it and do whatever the [__] they want
after that. But yeah, why do you do do I
have to accept 5,000 pull request from a
guy who created an account yesterday?
Maybe it changed. Oh, that's us. Let's
go. You have people opening update of MD
files just to have some contribution
>> and they just update the date or
whatever just to show that they can do
something
>> just to build up your resume and saying
yeah I have like 200 contribution.
>> You see the same thing on on WordPress.
You can just have cloud app managing
your browser, putting in all the
translations, pushing it and you you
were the one adding something to that
project and then you can show your
customers, hey, I've been working on so
many projects and my name is here, here,
and here. And
>> people who don't get it, they just think
that you're doing a lot of good things
for WordPress and they give you a new
project. But don't you think that
eventually people will start it because
they have an idea, they put it online,
and then AI will take over. It will just
keep on improving.
>> Improving what? Like your open source
code.
>> Yeah. Because eventually why would an AI
create open source because it can build
everything at once. So usually open
source comes from people having issues
trying to find a good solution,
publishing it online. Other people have
the same issue and everybody starts
building together and then you get a
bigger and bigger project and eventually
a big open-source project. But I think
as soon as you start pushing it online
and like a few people start using it,
then the AIs come in because they put
the AI on it to improve it.
>> Why AI is not writing all of the open
source code in the universe?
>> I think eventually it will. It will just
take a few more updates.
>> Yeah.
>> And all the problems that he's
discussing right now in his videos, they
will be gone.
>> Yeah. Exactly. And do you think like
there is still a future even like for
closed source anyway?
>> Yeah, I think there will be. But if you
have a job where your um employer is
asking you to write down everything you
do and to document everything,
[laughter] then you're going to be
jobless.
>> You need to document everything because
then you also like create a process for
the rest of the team to like work like
you, right? But now the rest of the team
is like five agents.
>> Yes.
[laughter]
>> And I think that's a good question to
conclude a video.
>> Yeah. If you know the answer, write it
down.
>> Exactly. Please comment and subscribe so
we can see you next week.
>> Yes.
>> On the live stream and on the channel.
Mitchell, thank you so much for your
time. We appreciate the chitchat.
>> Yes. Thank you, Vincent.
You're welcome. [laughter]